une 78e édition du paris-nice une
nouvelle fois au départ du 78 la course
au soleil s'élancera depuis le
département des yvelines pour la onzième
année consécutive lors de chaque rendez
vous les organisateurs doivent se
renouveler et créent de nouveaux tracés
objectif surprendre les spectateurs
depuis onze ans on voit quand même pas
mal de choses les trois dernières années
encore davantage de choses quand les
conditions atmosphériques climatique s'y
met avec du vent envoie en convoi des
bordures on voit tout un tas de tout un
tas de choses
donc c'est ça le vélo aujourd'hui donc
il faut absolument qu'on trouve nous
organisateurs des terrains de jeux et
les yvelines nous offre la possibilité
donc de mettre en place ces terrains
cette année la ville de plaisir a été
choisi comme terrain pour accueillir la
première étape de cette édition 2020 le
départ sera donné le dimanche 8 mars
depuis la commune
le peloton fera une boucle de 154 km à
travers les yvelines en passant par ben
montfort l'amaury ou encore
neauphle-le-château une satisfaction
pour plaisir qui a attendu de nombreuses
années avant d'être ville départ de
l'épreuve
ça nous ferons les chaque année mais
cette fois ci c'est vraiment bien
installé surtout que le village va être
dans le parc du château qui est un lieu
de rassemblement familial est un lieu de
rassemblement festif pour l'ensemble de
la ville
donc voilà on n'attendait que ça le
lendemain ses chevaux aux moins de 6000
habitants qui accueillera le départ de
la deuxième étape vers le loiret et des
stars internationales comme julian
alaphilippe o'hagan bernal la commune
sera la 19e ville des yvelines à être
village départ de l'épreuve chevaux est
considéré par les spécialistes comme une
terre de cyclisme
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit qui est
particulièrement prisée des amateurs de
vélo
beaucoup de professionnels aussi qui
viennent faire leur pré saison et leur
mise en route en ce moment d'ailleurs
sur les routes de la vallée de chevreuse
donc c'est un endroit qui s'y prêtent
vraiment et que je pense les cyclistes
apprécié l'histoire d'amour entre les
yvelines et le paris nice n'est pas
prête de s'arrêter le partenariat qui
devait s'achever en 2021 devrait être
reconduit cette année pour quatre
nouvelles éditions supplémentaires